muere una monarca de 70 años de reino en
pleno siglo 21 en el año 2022 qué
impacto cree usted que puede tener esto
en el papel de la monarquía no en reino
unidos sino a nivel internacional
pues muere a la monarca más longeva de
la historia en 70 años de monarquía
habiendo pasado momentos difíciles todas
las turbulencias de la segunda mitad del
siglo 20 siendo además la monarca de una
de las potencias más importantes del
mundo lo que trae ahora mismo es una
sensación de inestabilidad
se esconde en estabilidad por el cambio
no porque existan mecanismos que pueden
llevar a ello por lo tanto está por ver
un poco cuál es la indicación cuál es el
proceso que va que va a aplicar el nuevo
monarca carlos 30 y cómo va a retomar un
poco los trabajo donde lo dejó lo deja a
su madre en un momento además que es muy
convulso lo que ponemos en la crisis
económica mundial el tema de la línea
etc
así que muchas preguntas es el momento
de interesante que evidentemente pues
impacta en una institución una
institución molar que en general porque
es la monarca más importante después de
la historia reciente pues ha fallecido y
esto pues genera muchas preguntas sobre
qué va a pasar que puede ser hasta qué
punto una monarquía pues digamos tiene
tiene el papel que tiene pero bueno eso
hay que esperar un poco los próximos
días para ver qué cómo evoluciona el
proceso pero en un país como el reino
unido con un poco la popularidad de la
monarquía tan alta creo este que cabe
ese debate o qué es un debate y que
simplemente no tiene cabida como ocurre
en otros países por ejemplo españa
bueno el debate del republicanismo en el
reino unido- estado presente desde
siempre siempre habido esa idea de hecho
una de las cosas que surge aquí mucho
ahora mismo es el tema de que digamos
que es lo que es lo que va a pasar con
la institución no siempre está ese papel
de institución depende mucho del
material que éste isabel segunda era un
digamos una figura muy muy estadio del
respecto no creo que haya ningún cambio
no va digamos no creo que pase nada yo
creo que el país me importa más
importante es desgastado han comentado
anteriormente va a ser las dudas más
importantes van a surgir en el papel de
váter la monarquía como jefe de estado
los 14 es el rotor de países de la
commonwealth dónde todavía es un divo de
barbuda ya no lo es pero donde digamos
dónde donde lo va a ser en muchos países
donde pues el el cambio no el caso de
volar y las repúblicas es siempre se ha
visto
o sea se ha metido en el debate
y demás
si hablan siguiendo la línea de lo que
comentábamos antes con un invitado
previo que este debate como creo este
que va a afectar por ejemplo australia
un país que en donde se debate un poco
más de latente si él pues vamos vamos a
ver ahí que hay una cosa es interesante
hay muchos y hay unos miembros del
gobierno estrógeno que tienen que ir al
reino unido ahora mismo son parte de lo
que se llama el el consejo de sucesión
mañana tienen que probar a
carlos trocero como rey él evidentemente
nuestro aliado importante que es
simplemente
desprenderse
de esa figura moral que es una figura
colonial y que estado y todo haya estado
presentes desde hace mucho tiempo no es
digamos no es no es nuevo la muerte de
digamos de isabel segunda genera nuevo
revitalización de esas
de esas ideas las relaciones sea lo que
puede cambiar un poco las relaciones
históricas que tienen estabilidad con
pues con los antiguos miembros no con
los mejores de la commonwealth pues con
la antigua metrópoli no con el reino
unido en el día a día en el día práctico
no digamos los cambios casi no no se van
a notar el real estado en este caso la
remesa del segundo
tenía pocos y no ninguno poder ejecutivo
directo no sobre sobre el día a día
político pero es simbólicamente es muy
importante simbólicamente es muy
importante romper lazos digamos de los
lazos de digamos dentro de la selva
commonwealth romper lazos dentro de edad
la relación existía tradicional tener
unidos antigua colonia y veremos un poco
qué es lo que es lo que ocurre al
respecto australia es el ejemplo más
importante pues uno de los países más
importantes no los los tres grandes
países que ahora mismo pues están en la
digamos en la en la palestra respecto a
este tema es el que son los países
tienen que ver porque no lo hace la cndh
a canadá
canadá y australia y el y la piel y
veremos a ver este delante va a surgir
en otros muchos países otros nosotros 11
países donde todavía la reina siempre
sigue siendo de estado va a surgir
también de una manera mucho más mucho
más fuerte pero bueno esperemos a ver
veremos yo no no aquí sino que ocurre
acá que ocurre a grandes cambios si
habrá el debate y veremos esto toca toca
ver ahora qué ocurrió